[Music]
look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
phoenix felt like iron's blade with
every step
its weight a reminder of the heavy
responsibility
you gave him your blade oh i feel it
i meant to ask why exactly would you
expect to receive a sword from achilles
or as an offering just a routine
offering from someone
who gazed into your eyes and told you
you were special
that's all i left to rose
on his breastplate got something in my
eyes
keep going
prometheus stop with the mortal bitty
party and get to the action part
now that's more likely
[Music]
shed by typhon's minions metal of the
gods
threw itself to phoenix as if wanting to
be forged
into something greater
i'll have to swim to the other shore
huh
hello can you hear me in there
i'm coming
i found your axe phoenix approached the
axe
feeling it called to her
looks like the acts of atalanta must be
a copy
although but before phoenix could claim
it
the axe was pulled into the pit by a
terrible force
who knocks upon my
to the sailors
what what is this place
indeed what was this strange
place it's tartarus just exactly where
had phoenix landed the nasty abyss where
i imprisoned title
he must have opened rifts into the
vaults of the underworld when he escaped
you know it i know it say it phoenix
wasn't uh
sure i hate you but aren't you intrigued
no keep going
you are either brave little one
or very foolish let's see if you can
meet my challenge or if you will fall
like all the others who are you
hello
hmm
uh
huh
what's this winx
ran her hands over them noticing that
several pieces were missing
as if someone had ripped them apart
they seem to be man-made i wonder how
they work
if they even work
whoa they actually work
sort of
the axe
the acts of atalanta deadliest of
hunters
swiftest of heroes falling at the hands
of typhon
didn't i change her into a lion you
turned a lot of people into a lot of
things
i need to stop drinking
you're still standing
[Music]
scattered hidden by typhon it's over
phoenix is helios no one can handle
those bolts but
me oh really
[Music]
no way power
surged through phoenix it was too much
for her to bear
what's happening to me bye bye mortal
and then just like that
[Music]
the winds grounded the lightning they
were designed to withstand storms
that shouldn't be possible and yet
this is just the beginning
having plunged into the abyss of
tartarus and living to tell the tale
phoenix emerged victorious for
now that stranger i was chasing
where did he go with the wings
she would be able to flit across the
ancient bridge and find out
i wouldn't just step on this guarded
junk who knows where those have been
many a night phoenix had told tales of a
genius
an inventor named daedalus and his
extraordinary wings
perhaps someone copied their design
phoenix
muse so junk ooh
maybe it's cursed